i just feel like youtuber content is the
natural progression to like anyone who
really got into the waifu culture yeah
like like like we
like us like you less so but i mean i've
got i've gotten into it but i guess i
wonder why i haven't gone
on the after deep end yet i mean i i i
would say you never
stepped i mean obviously you never went
to the deep end with the waifu culture
you just kind of like
you kind of you kind of appreciate it to
me
who's your best girl who's your waifu
connor
yeah yeah yeah that's it no because this
is
i do you you can't do that's a loaded
question if you can't answer that's
in five seconds and then you don't have
a why it's like saying what's your
favorite genocide there's no right
someone's gonna be angry like
that's the point of life because man you
can't please anyone
i can i can immediately answer that
question fine
okay because she's a goat man yeah she
is because i
i for some reason i like
the whole rented girlfriend thing sounds
so [ __ ] fun i would love to do that
job that sounds fun
i would love to be in a situation to
test my acting skills yeah
to be someone else's like to meet their
grandma and have to worry about
that sounds like fun does that make me
psychotic does that
a little i mean that's kind of that's
kind of what you do on your youtube
channel basically yeah i mean you just
did an entire [ __ ] series where you
just had a bunch of well that wasn't
that serious but i would love to like
actually try and like
[ __ ] pretend and see if it would be
believable i don't know why
some people definitely call that
sociopathic probably that's a little
social i think isn't it
what was the point of this oh i i i
think she's a goat man she's just a goat
man
i thought he loves you yeah i know you
just made a [ __ ] video about it
yeah the point is genocide is bad
okay when the whole waifu culture right
right
is it like a thing where when i would
like
i would fight for my favorite wifey yeah
yeah i felt like it was a thing where it
was like
i genuinely like this character but i'm
putting on an act like i don't
actually care about them that much like
i'm just i figured that everyone was the
same where it's like oh we're 100 yeah
we're all 100 that this is why this is
why we're both taking men
yeah like i i'm i'm getting [ __ ]
married
because like you're like your
relationships aren't satisfied you're
like
god i gotta find something else to just
fill that up because because
i i see waifu's in a totally different
realm than i see real people because i
think that'll be
like that has to be stated
some people are like when they say oh
your 2d is better than 3d
most people just say it as a guy that's
what i thought i thought everyone's just
joking
i've met some people who are
legitimately like nah [ __ ] 3d women like
yeah
yeah exactly but we're not like that we
just say that as a [ __ ] gag
you've had your fill of the three yeah
yeah you're not satisfied
i like the idea of like the waifus or
some of some like
life what's the idea sorry the idea that
you can sing for them but there's no
actual repercussions to them yeah
because i heard that the word simp has
been invented
because now now it just it it replaces
all nuance of like explaining the
feeling
here's the thing you can simp for an
actual real person
but you can't see it for a reason but
you can't
but you can't see him for an anime
character just that's just not how it
works
but i think some people just tend to
think like oh yeah i can simp an anime
character but you can't
you they're not even real you can't simp
if they don't exist you can't sleep if
they don't exist
i i guess like i know i don't know why i
just seem to like i was under the
impression that everyone was like
pretending to act like to feel this
strongly about it oh no no
i'm sure there are some people i mean i
thought that we were all just like like
yeah i'll kill you for rem
yeah like i don't think anyone actually
was like serious about that stuff no i
mean i i'm not serious about that i mean
that's that's part of the fun of it
right we all agreed that it's like
no no did you think we won wait we
weren't what sorry like
did you honestly think that if you said
like oh yeah was [ __ ] that i would come
out
after you with a [ __ ] knife no no no
no because i thought that's what you
just said
no no no no i was under the impression
that everyone was like we're all
pretending to feel this strongly we are
serious but we're not like i will
[ __ ] commit genocide no no no no it's
it's it's not it's not pretending
because you feel strongly
like this is what i'm saying like i feel
like i've met some people
who can't turn that [ __ ] off and they
don't know if it isn't that i think
that's the thing
we have we can we can turn it off but
there are so many
yeah we no we can turn it all right
right but that's because we have a break
and we can turn it off this is what some
people can't turn like you know how
people
think like everyone just agrees the moon
landing didn't happen right it's like
that this is actually a conspiracy
theory i was like we all agree that
we're acting right when we talk about
these white people this is
actually a conspiracy theory where no
one actually feels strongly
define feel strongly yeah right what do
you mean by feel strongly
you would never get upset like genuinely
upset like
i'm talking like like crying over
something to do with your fictional
character
some people will though some people will
i mean it's this is
not to do with the story like this is
like stuff to do with like outside
emotions that you're bringing in no some
people will
why i mean i mean why i mean we're not
that people what
what you're describing is exactly the
same way as people who [ __ ] on your
favorite anime you know what i mean like
you've you've seen the reactions where
if if you if you [ __ ] on some anime
people you're gonna like read
the episode hasn't gone live yet well we
should on the fan dubs but i'm sure
we'll see
you've seen the smear campaign that went
against like me when i said that fairy
tale was [ __ ] right like
there was it was a sneak out they were
like they were like
still getting hit they were like defend
fairy tale from the anime man i'm like
i'm not the only person who said that
fairy tale [ __ ]
but that but that's the thing they're
they're varying degrees
do you think the the the whole like
simping over the the waifus and stuff is
just the extension of the show and the
like of the show
it's it's kind of the same emotional
attachment you know as the
as the resident wife zoologist i just
made that title up
but really i would never have guessed
that i really didn't have to clarify
that but
i i've always found waifu culture like
super fascinating
also because like i i love because it's
like it's an act that everyone agrees to
just play along with yeah but like
at what point is here's what's
interesting at what point
is like the attachment you feel towards
the waifu
at what point do we all agree that it
becomes unhealthy
right because like to me i i can
to me i can clearly separate my love
towards a fictional character right
right right
i love my love towards like real people
because i can safely say that
some of the some of like my favorite
waifus they would be [ __ ] [ __ ] if
they existed in real life like
my god that's what you get for liking
soon there imagine like
imagine having a real life cinderella
who [ __ ] hits you
for like the stupidest [ __ ] you know
which which is what
i don't understand about people who say
that tsundere is i mean i can't really
say speaking
mine's the same but like at least my
wife who doesn't like
hit people like for no [ __ ] reason
right your waifu
hits people for no [ __ ] reason these
men are disgusting as if it's like man
if she was real what would she do to me
no no because it's weird right because
no one defined the rules on how to
act about or talk about it but
everyone's just kind of had this
agreement but
that we're gonna act and all engage in a
way like like it's a sports team yeah
it's just like a common sense thing
right but some people have taken it too
fast
some people i mean there's always going
to be people right it's like fantasy
football some people just take it a
little too far and a little too
seriously even though
they know it doesn't exist yeah yeah
well i'd say when people like give [ __ ]
to
the team they're like you [ __ ] i
had ten dollars on this [ __ ] yeah
why did you not go